hi i'm farin cousins in for david pakman
and this is the david pakman show
obviously biggest news in the world
right now we've got to just jump right
into this and that is the deteriorating
situation
in afghanistan
over the weekend
the afghani president was forced to
evacuate the country leaving the capital
in kabul to fall
to the taliban
the taliban have been encroaching
throughout the country over the last
week or so in really
spectacular fashion uh you know just
taking over as much as they can and now
it appears
with them having seized the capital
uh we're in for quite the situation
right and if you've been following
social media over the weekend i'm sure
you've seen plenty of people
with opinions about what should and
should not happen in the country right
now
you've got the corporate controlled
media and of course all the republicans
out there
telling us we've got to double down
biden himself sending 5 000 more troops
over the last week back to afghanistan
when we're supposed to be getting all of
our people out of afghanistan u.s
embassy has had to be evacuated as well
and then of course you have the other
side you have the people who say listen
you can't send anybody over there
this is a 20-year trillion dollar
endless war
get the hell out and stay out
unfortunately
it's not as easy as all of these
armchair military strategists would have
you believe it's not as simple as the
united states sending thousands of
troops over there we'll get the taliban
out of the country again and oh
everything will be great not that simple
it's not as simple as walking around
saying oh well
we created this mess good luck dealing
with it that destabilizes you know the
region
so what is the answer
i don't know
i don't know and i i'm firmly willing to
admit
that i don't know
and i think that's a problem that a lot
of folks have in this business whether
it's right or left
always desperate
to have a definitive answer
as to what we need to do and they're
always so sure of that answer but folks
like i said
i think this is a situation that's not
as black and white as a lot of people
want to make it seem
i personally do not want any u.s troops
going back to afghanistan
but at the same time we have to also
look at what we did to that country we
did this over 20 years
we helped to destabilize not just
afghanistan but the entire
region
with our ridiculous
and false foreign policy based on lies
then obama kept us there
trump acted like he was going to get us
out you know tried to negotiate with the
taliban but that didn't do much good and
so biden
comes along and says well we're going to
finish getting out of there
we didn't
now we're going back
so what is the solution
you know can we just sit here and say
okay taliban afghanistan is yours we
screwed it up maybe you can do better
i obviously don't think we can do that
is the answer sending thousands more
troops back to the country to just put
it back in the situation it was in
before we even left that's also a
terrible idea
unfortunately
there's no easy answers
and any answer we have has to address
the fact that the united states has made
this situation so much worse
the taliban now has their hands on all
these u.s weapons
that we've been sending over there for
decades now
they've got the strongholds they have
forced us out they have forced the
afghan government
out
and they say they're now waiting for a
peaceful transfer of power
so
again i i don't have a definitive answer
one suggestion
i have at this point
is we need to do what george w bush
originally talked about doing until he
pissed off all our allies
is we we need a coalition
the united states has proven that uh we
can't handle the situation there we
never went in with an actual strategy
so it's kind of hard 20 years after the
fact to really be able to get a good
solid strategy a really good ground game
going because we never had one to begin
with
so everybody else that comes along all
the other leaders obama trump and biden
they're having to piece it together as
they go
and nobody got it right
i mean what's happening right now in
afghanistan is proof that nobody got it
right the only difference is that for
all of those years the uh taliban
really only had control
on the outskirts you know the really
rural areas of afghanistan that's that's
where they were able to
you know see progress that's when we
were able to fight them back
and as soon as we leave they come back
so the answer is not obviously sending
more troops over there for another 20
years so we have another generation of
american soldiers growing up
as part of this war machine that that
that's not that's not tenable that's not
something we can do
i do think
the the best path forward at this point
and again i'm not a military strategist
don't claim to be
but if we do not have a solid coalition
of allies
if we cannot get other countries
involved
to
pledge
to protect this area
you know if we have to negotiate with
the taliban then we have to negotiate at
this point
but honestly i i don't know what else
and it all stems from those failures of
the war on terror
we have had republicans try this we have
had democrats try this this is now
bipartisan failure
with regards to our our afghanistan
foreign policy
so the solution is not going to come
from the united states
we need people that are better at this
we need people who can look at it a
little more objectively than the united
states can because we're still stuck in
that war on terror mentality that
followed the attacks of 9 11.
we're still not thinking clearly at this
point and and again what's happening
right now is further proof of that
so if we can't get some cooler heads in
there if we can't get some real true
allies
you know maybe other nations in the
region
that can help us out
then this is what it is and we're stuck
with this mess that we created
and in the meantime until we figure this
out the united states need to say listen
we're going to take afghan refugees
over the weekend
tens of thousands of people daily
trying to get out of the country because
they see what's happening they
understand
this is for real
okay this isn't a temporary insurgency
here that we're seeing this is what
their life may become now
and i would say after 20 years of
occupying their country
after helping to destabilize it
i'd say that's the least we could do is
take these people into our country and
that is the next step that i want to see
this biden administration take
acknowledge the failures of the united
states acknowledge that we don't have
the answers yet
and that is a terrifying thing for a
country to admit and i guarantee you
you'll never hear them say that
but at least we can do that
me everybody watching this
all of the other people left and right
out there with the armchair punditry
admit that we don't know
how to correctly handle this situation
because it sucks to have to admit that
you don't know it
but i think at this point that's where
we're at
and i don't think anybody can
definitively say that yes we i know for
certain we have to do this or we can't
do that
it's not that simple
but we're going to continue to watch
as the corporate media cnn's already out
there the major newspapers already out
there oh my god this is horrible we got
to get troops back there they're going
to push for war because war means
ratings war means advertisements
and that's what makes them money
on the other side of all of this
you have the republicans out there
non-stop over the weekend telling us
that this is a failure of the biden
administration this failure rests solely
on his shoulders
and whether it's fair or not
it does
he is the leader of the country right
now
this was a decision that was made
and so if
it succeeds or fails that is on him
and you may think it's fair you may
think it's not fair but it doesn't
matter politically speaking yes it is on
him
and republicans are going to do
everything they can to use that to their
advantage especially heading into the
midterms
look as we all know republicans have
struggled terrifically
trying to come up with any kind of
talking point
to take down joe biden
you know going as far a couple months
ago to blame him for the chick-fil-a
sauce shortage
this is one that might stick
and that's even more terrifying folks
because if the midterm elections and
especially if the 2024 presidential
elections
become about failed foreign policy
and people get mad at the democrat who
inherited all of it and again i think
it's rather unfair for that to happen
but i understand that that is what is
going to happen then we're going to end
up with something terrible
that's a situation where you end up with
somebody like tom cotton coming out and
saying oh my god we've got to get back
over there look at all this instability
the democrats created the terrorists
have taken over i've been there
i know what it's like over there
and i know what we can do and people
will flock to that i promise you
i can promise you that because we've
seen it happen we saw it happen in the
2004 election
turmoil in the middle east
and the republicans unfortunately did a
much better job of messaging saying
we're the only ones that can keep you
safe
they did it through misinformation they
did it through lies they did it through
fake news and all of that yes
but it worked on the american public
so 2024 could end up being a repeat of
the 2004 election
based on that simple fact
and again that's the situation where you
end up with somebody worse you end up
with the worst kind of war hawk at the
top of that republican ticket
who's going to do unimaginable things
over there in the middle east where all
of this is taking place because it's not
just going to be about afghanistan
either they're going to throw in iran
they're going to throw in syria they're
going to say look at all these
democratic failures abroad
that's bad news
that is bad
news for the democratic party
and it's bad news for the united states
as well and it's bad news for everybody
over there in the middle east because
again we end up with somebody worse and
i i picked tom cotton because he is
somebody that served this could be the
kind of event that a guy like him needs
to really bolster up his poll numbers
because trust me he's not doing well
so far and all the little straw polls
for 2024 so this could be the moment
that tom cotton emerges
as their guy as the republicans guy
you know ron desantis doesn't have that
ted cruz certainly doesn't have that
donald trump obviously doesn't have that
although he is going to try to use this
to his advantage as well
but the point is we can't go back to a
situation whether it is with a democrat
or a republican
where we think that we can bomb our way
out of the problem that's never going to
work
we tried it for 20
years
and an abrupt pullout here saying well
best of luck to you all while it's best
for us troops sure
we've destabilized the region created
hundreds of thousands of you know
evacu refugees at this point not just
evacuees but refugees
with nowhere to go
and we have to own that as a country
as an administration they have to own
that
they may not have started this mess
but they've been with it every step of
the way unfortunately
so we have to do better we have to do
better for these people we have to do
better for the world and we have to get
more people on our side willing to take
a leadership role take it away from us i
feel
and we can offer the the support that
they need
i do not want another conflict in the
middle east i do not want more war i do
not want more dead soldiers whether it's
u.s soldiers or whether it's a foreign
country soldiers we don't need that at
all
so we have to put our best and brightest
together we got to get the intelligence
and i don't mean like covert and i mean
like literal intelligence
the smart people in the room need to
take things over and they need to get
with the other smartest people around
the country and try to figure out a way
that this doesn't end with more bombs
and more bloodshed but unfortunately i
do not think
that the cooler heads are going to
prevail in this situation and that is
not going to end well for anybody
i'm faring cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back
i've struggled falling asleep at night
and realized part of it could be because
of the blue light coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that blue light can
suppress the hormone melatonin which can
make it difficult to fall asleep blue
light can disturb your circadian rhythms
but it hasn't been an issue for me since
i discovered blue blocks glasses which
filter out that blue light they're one
of our sponsors a lot of other companies
are mass producing supposed blue light
glasses and factories with no actual
quality standards blue blocks glasses
are made in actual optics labs at their
headquarters in australia they have over
40 stylish frames a prescription version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that
blueblox sells they give a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
you'll get 20 off when you go to
blueblocks.com pacman the link is right
underneath this video and there's free
shipping worldwide on orders over 115
dollars